We fear the idea of personal change...
...because we think that we have to sacrifice something to give something up.
But human beings, at our best, are so inventive and creative and ingenious.
And I think that when we use love and compassion as our guiding principles,...
...we can create, develop and implement systems of change...
...that are beneficial to all sentient beings and to the environment.
I've been a scoundrel all my life.
I have been selfish.
I've been cruel at times, hard to work with and ungrateful.
But, so many of you in this room have given me a second chance.
And I think that's when we're at our best:...
...when we support each other. Not when we cancel each other out for past mistakes,...
...but when we help each other to grow, when we educate each other,...
...when we guide each other towards redemption.
That is the best of humanity.
When he was 17, my brother wrote this lyric.
He said, "Run to the rescue with love and peace will follow."
Thank you.